you know like if you're being called
upon to lie
or to bury your head in the sand
well where's that gonna end
it's not it's not gonna stop
that it isn't how it works as far as i
can tell so
yeah it has to be something like that
and i i mean i'm not saying these are
easy decisions i'm certainly not saying
that i made the right decision i hope
that they'd have to cart my skeleton out
of the university of toronto you know i
liked my job a lot it was it was just
fine
and
you know it's been nothing but chaos and
upheaval since then i'm i mean i have
been rewarded but
i haven't been rewarded with
security something like that that's not
the right word exactly
stability maybe yeah well it's high risk
high reward fine but i would have
settled for much less reward and much
less risk
so and i was perfectly happy with that
now i'm not ungrateful for what i've
accrued in the meantime but
but it's not an improvement that's for
sure and i wouldn't lecture people about
you know their moral obligation because
you've pointed out the problem it's the
proximal cost and the distal reward
right you know you see a system
degenerating and you're going to say
something and the cost you is going to
be bloody high and that impact is going
to be perhaps not even measurable
but then you run into the problem that
heather just described which is well
if seventy percent of you don't like
what's going on and you don't say
anything then you know where is it going
to end
and people have to make those moral
decisions for themselves the only thing
that i know perhaps is that
lying doesn't seem like a good idea and
being forced to
particularly you know this is where i
took my stand i'm not saying other
things that other people want me to say
it's like up yours you go and live the
consequences of your speech and all live
the consequences of mine
and i'm not going to live the
consequences of your speech and that's
where my government went too far as far
as i was concerned it's like no no
compelled speech i don't give a damn
what your rationale is because i don't
why should i trust your rationale when
you're transgressing against something
so sacred
why would i possibly trust your
rationale there isn't anything more
sacred than the word
i mean unless you want to just dispense
with with with our accrued morality in
its entirety the one thing we've more or
less agreed on in the
[Music]
you know relatively christian west or
perhaps the judeo-christian west is that
the word is sacred
well if you want to throw that out be my
guest but you're not getting me to throw
that out
so now whether i'm right about that or
not well probably you know right christ
there's lots of ways i'm not right i can
tell you that but
why is it not a good idea
and you say that lying is not a good
idea do we need to redefine
the meaning of courage
in particular when we look at courage
what it used to mean and generations
past going to war
we're really you look at a lot of the
courageous people now they tend to be
whistleblowers they tend to be people
who stand out from the crowd
and say that they don't agree
do we need to redefine what it means to
be courageous
i think that's always been the case i
mean if you look at the prophetic
tradition in the old testament that's
just one story after another of society
degenerating towards a tyrannical state
and a prophetic voice emerging you know
representative of god in some abstract
sense saying
be careful you're deviating from the
proper path and if you don't think
they're going to be consequences
you're just not paying enough attention
well you know how do you distinguish a
false prophet from a true prophet i
don't know maybe the false prophet tells
you what you want to hear
i guess i would just add to that that i
think physical courage and mental
courage are related that there's a
reason that we use one word for both
and that in the modern world there is
far less opportunity to manifest
physical courage or to know what it
would be like
and you know it's been it's been much
discussed and i agree with the sense
that
you know
the lack of war is both beautiful and um
in some ways demasculinizing for for
society um not having that as even a
possibility on the horizon um and there
you know there's plenty of things that
that girls and women do as well that
requires physical courage but it tends
to look different and in our disembodied
behind screens especially for the last
you know especially during covet era
um just you know a physical lives
without having any sense of what
physical courage might be or what
physical risk might be of course we're
now also more confused about mental
courage and so you know being told
things like
silence is violence and also speech is
violent so you know the whole thing the
whole thing just falls apart very
quickly
uh before we go to our break and the q a
jordan i just want to come back to you
on this because i'm i'm not satisfied
with the conversation we've had so far
and that's maybe because there is no
answer but i just feel like
i've had so many conversations with
people where i've said exactly the same
thing to them lying is bad it has
consequences if we carry on down this
path we will go to a very bad place and
we're already in a very bad place and
the answer is yeah you're just
exaggerating it's just the pendulum
swinging the other way it will swing
back everything will be fine and even if
it's not well at least i get to survive
today you go and die i'll survive today
what what does one say to something like
that
they might be right
you know you just can't tell can you i
mean
let's say the pendulum does swing back
well maybe it swings back because people
stopped it from swinging too far but
then the people who said it's going to
swing back will say well we said it was
going to swing back and look they're
right there it went well that's why you
can't in some sense make your moral
determinations as a consequence even of
the analysis of an outcome
i think that's partly why something like
faith is necessary so do you have faith
in truth
well prove to me that truth is the best
path well i can't
that's not provable and for exactly the
reasons that you just laid out it's a
decision you make at some point
and
and you weigh the evidence you stake
your life on you know you're either
incoherent and all over the place which
is its own catastrophe or you stake your
life on a certain set of principles uh
you do that
you have to do one of those two things
you're either incoherent or you're
coherent if you're coherent you stake
your existence on some axiomatic
principles they're basically axioms of
faith
and you have to
decide what those are and then you live
out the consequences of that and
that's each individual soul's journey
and
i i'm not even sure you can convince
people in some sense i mean you can talk
to people and you can tell them what you
think and you can let them make up their
own mind it's one thing i learned as a
therapist and i watch therapists on tv
all the time they're always telling
their clients what to do i didn't tell
my clients what to do i didn't know what
the hell they should do
i mean they were different people than
me
and i didn't want to take
ownership of their victories or
responsibility for their defeats you
know that's not a good thing and so i
was always trying to help them figure
out what they should do and
you know in so far i think as i've been
successful in my lecturing
capability it's that's because i'm doing
that for the people i'm talking to i'm
not saying you have to believe this you
know it's
people wrestle with their own conscience
but you know we are forced to violate
your conscience
something's up either your conscience is
malfunctioning or the thing that's
forcing you to violate it is becoming
tyrannical i don't what are the other
options
[Music]